do you need a vacation
i got a great question from my video
producer
christina now if you're liking the
videos that you're seeing christina has
a hand in all of them
put in the beginning intro music effects
all of that's cristina's hard work
and she just came back from a vacation
to engar watt and she wrote in to say
how about a theme for the video is there
a need for vacation to reload your brain
to work better
this is a really interesting topic for
me so i think it's great to go on
vacation i
i equate going on vacation to
learning something new gaining new
experiences because when you
are learning something new
you're able to bring more to your
business you're able to add more value
you're able to make more money as a
result you have new creative ideas
if you're stuck doing the same thing
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over
again
you get bored it gets boring life gets
boring you stop thinking of creative
ways to make things different
and you can get stuck in a rut where you
you don't know what to do you just know
that your life sucks
you don't know how you got here and you
don't know how to escape
so you need to find ways for you to grow
and try new things and vacationing is a
great way to do it
i love going on vacations i try to do
two long ones
per year and then two shorter ones per
year
and i find that i get tons of new ideas
and new energy
just seeing how business is done in
europe or seeing how entrepreneurs are
kicking in asia what they're up to
gives me ideas on what i can do for my
business
i think it also adds to to your
knowledge level
and to your creativity so
this goes beyond just vacationing it's
just trying out new things i could talk
about
salsa dancing or i could talk about
snowboarding or i could talk about
playing the piano or get a new condo or
cooking or things that i'm
learning and and growing with i can
share those experiences and that makes
me better at what i'm doing so you want
to be able to constantly reach out and
try new things you're not just stuck in
a rut over and over and over again
what i don't think about vacation should
be is an escape
a lot of people who are in crappy jobs
and jobs that they hate
they they can't wait for a vacation to
come but for me it's like
an extended weekend right if you are in
a business
or at a job where you can't wait for the
weekend to come
and that that's when you have fun if you
hate your life and you can't wait for
your vacation to come
and that's your escape then then
i mean it's great that you have that
vacation
but something is wrong with your life
right
vacationing shouldn't be an escape from
your life it should be an extension of
it
so you should be doing things in your
life that you enjoy and you're proud of
and that build you and that
you are passionate about and and going
on vacation
and trying out new experiences is just a
supplement to that
i think vacation is important i think it
helps you as an entrepreneur
i would just examine what are the
reasons for going on that vacation if
it's so you can learn something bring it
back
put it into your business that's great
go for it if it's
i want to escape my life because i hate
what i'm doing then you need to sit down
and examine your life
and fix it because the vacation is just
a band-aid
it's not going to help you get to where
you need to go that's my take
believe thanks for the question
christina for those of you watching you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below
let me know what you think you'll go on
vacation how often
what's your view leave in the comments
below you have a question
leave it for me i'll make a video
response subscribe to the channel if you
like these videos
thank you so much and i'll see you soon
you